spring 2022 is over and there's one
thing i noticed about the season not
exactly a late realization but something
that didn't come up immediately this
season albeit strong features a lot of
rom-coms comedies and mystery shows
check out the top shows in the seasonal
charts the ones that everyone's talking
about we have expected hits like spy
family gaguya and shikimori as well as
unexpected sleeper hits like kong ming
overall not a lot of action anime and
even perennial favorite shield hero
seems to have its first season momentum
staggered but what about my seasonal
fights videos sure spy family has some
action but you know that's not what
we're here to talk about right well
don't even worry even in this season
that doesn't seem to have a lot of
fighting i managed to find some battles
that will get your heart racing and that
adrenaline flowing so let's get to it
the top 10 fights of the spring 2022
season here we go how about a chill
fight to start the list here's ark vs
basilisk
skeleton night in another world may not
have become a mainstream hit this season
but it's a refreshing change of pace
people have jokingly called it the light
mode eins show and it's easy to see why
to easily establish the contrast of this
show from other serious power fantasy
isakai's we have this early fight
against the basilisk if you were to ask
me i like how the fight maintained the
air of tension despite there being a
light-hearted backdrop to it whereas
most isakai heroes would have dispatched
this random monster in a showcase of
power arc struggles a bit against it
fombles would be a better word for i
suppose as there's really that aura of
awkwardness beyond the display of wits
and bravery this fight does what it
needs to do establish skeleton knight in
another world's overall tone and appeal
as a more wholesome and light-hearted
isakai adventure
if you're up for a more serious
adventure in fantasyland here's i'm
quitting heroin
i'm not gonna lie before the season
started i'm quitting heroin wasn't on my
watch list however upon taking another
look at the chance and the premises of
each show i decided to give it a shot in
the end it's got an interesting and
unique gimmick to separate itself from
the rest of the pack and so far i'm
liking what it's been doing with the
age-old question what happens to the
hero after he's won it's also got some
great fights that the season saw he
needed such as leo fighting the four
generals bro really pulled the eren card
for the big twist as the anime heads
towards the end of its run and it's here
that we get a more direct proof of how
powerful hero leo really is he goads
them into battle one that he knows very
well that he can win without breaking a
sweat in the four against one fight he
easily shrugs off everything the
generals can throw at him all while
responding in kind the reversal of role
plays into the fight so well with how
much he's gloating and brushing off
everyone else leo really has that
villain role practice to perfection
don't you think
[Music]
the battle versus the spirit tortoise is
still pretty good
i said still pretty good because
honestly speaking there's quite some
changed content in this fight that could
have made it better shield hero's second
season is still something that i did
have fun with unfortunately i guess it's
about time for it to get hit with the
classic light novel adaptation disease
of cut or modified content guess that's
why the series seems to have fallen off
since the glory days of well just a few
years ago still the spirit tour choice
fight is exciting and enjoyable as its
own anime segment the voice acting the
production size of it like the visuals
and music are all on par for what you'd
want and they really did play up the
threat of this big boss by showing its
power and how it and the monsters mowed
down armies at the end we also get some
cool new skills from raftalia and the
gang but it just needed more build up
it's a good fight but i really hope you
can check out the manga or the novels
for this one the anime does try its best
but i feel there's still just something
lost in terms of the sheer magnitude of
the fight still if you're up for some
intense action that will get you hyped
in the same way boss raids do then this
is a nice representation of that
finae versus kubo is a simple fight
that's enjoyable
i didn't expect vampire in the garden to
be a fight heavy series but in the small
number of episodes we had the show still
gave us an enjoyable battle between
finney and kubo the two already had a
fight early on but it's nothing compared
to the spectacle and the decisiveness of
this last one i like the fight because
it's not just a battle between two
combatants instead it's a clash of
ideals just as good fights must be the
two represent two opposing values and
world views coexistence or hatred only
one can triumph in the end this second
fight retains the smoothness and the
fluidity of the first finae versus kubo
fight but now adds so much to the stakes
being the climax that we all needed it
also had no shortage of drama and
tension thanks to phineas vampiric
nature manifesting the netflix release
model is a true killer for an anime's
lifespan in the community consciousness
just look at the stone ocean and
summertime render still i implore you to
watch vampire in the garden it's a short
five episodes long but it's definitely
worth the journey
[Applause]
hibiki and ulta versus undertakers is
one of bubble's top highlights
bubble overall is a film that has quite
divided public opinion it's not
controversial by any means but the
reception has been mixed to say the
least what hasn't had a mixed reception
however is the universal agreement that
it's a masterpiece in terms of visuals
the artistic style the color quality the
sound direction and such are nothing
short of beautiful and there's no better
moment to illustrate all that than the
showdown between the protagonists and
the undertakers it's not as much of a
fight than an athletic race through the
skies and with the music and ambient
sounds like the people cheering you get
pulled into the moment this my friends
is wit at its best directing fast-paced
fights to take the audience on a ride a
bit less figuratively in this scene as
we follow the characters fly around and
take the battle to the skies while the
city collapses it helps that the music
adds so much to the seed especially when
the undertakers all go after ulta many
people have called this the best scene
in the movie i certainly agree which is
why i placed it so late in this fight
list
before continuing how about taking some
time to thank today's video sponsors
because if you're more of a strategist
than a fighter perhaps this game will
tickle your fancy introducing samadhi
mana a game that i recently found and i
just can't stop playing samadhi mana is
the latest in the popular genre of
tycoon games and you take the role of a
hot shot manager your goal helped baron
somebody build his army of undead for
him to return to the underworld in order
to do so you need to build farms manage
your resources recruit the best managers
and improve your structures to restore
the summity manner to its former glory
somebody mana will test your wits and
strategizing letting you spend hours on
end trying to find the most efficient
way to manage your resources be it
through training undead or upgrading the
proper structures other managers also
give you a helping hand and learning
their abilities and the bonuses they
provide can pay off big time in your
quest make sure to watch out for special
events in order to get even more perks
and rewards a fun game to pass the time
especially when you want to express your
brain muscles a bit somebody mana is
something i'd like to recommend to
everyone if you're interested in giving
this casual game a try all you have to
do is click the link in the description
box hours of fun and challenges await
for our next fight we have spriggans you
and jon taking on fat man and little boy
when i saw what spriggan was all about i
knew we'd have something like this
coming i'm talking about a frantic high
tension fight that pits the two
operatives against some of the fiercest
foes possible i know it's going to be
one of those thriller action anime but
to have enemies that employ some of the
craziest attacks that newcomers could
think come out of the left field this is
the wild action that we came here for
the pace and the intensity of the fight
was really well conveyed with how the
animators decided to do this scene i
mean it's quite a mess in a good way but
also not to the point where you don't
understand what's happening the camera
work is also great in emphasizing the
impact of the moves especially the
finishers spriggan might have felt a tad
bit condensed given that it's just six
episodes but in terms of fight
choreography and animation this one has
it all
[Music]
lastly we have everyone versus kaido and
big mom
has there been a fight in one piece that
has as much hype as this one if we're
talking about modern one piece i don't
think anything comes close to this one
when two of the biggest and the baddest
in kaido and big mom finally team up we
know the world will no fear but we know
luffy is the last person who would take
it lying down and the times knife for
the destin showdown between this unholy
alliance and the worst generation and
it's shown in goodness as we love it it
stretches for a lot of episodes showing
off a lot of growth in terms of our
heroes and a lot of moments backing up
the hype that kaido and big mom have
they're not the toughest competition our
heroes have faced so far for nothing and
they put on a spectacle for the whole
stretch of episodes but we also get a
lot of cool moments from the protagonist
as seeing luffy and zoro take the fight
to kaido is truly a sight to behold one
piece has had a share of hype moments
year in and year out but i don't think
anything from recent memory comes close
to how well this lived up to it i can't
wait to see the recent manga chapters
make it to the anime and that's
something for you guys to look forward
to
[Music]
and there you have it my top fight for
spring 2022 which one is the best in
your opinion what do you think whichever
it is i hope that this video did its job
of showing that despite not having a lot
of action titles spring 2022 still has
some pretty good fights some of which
you might have overlooked meanwhile you
can also check out my other channel
vinitube kai that has more video essays
or the more analytical stuff or simply
lists that deal with a more concise
focus on a particular title you can also
check out the channel's discord to join
the fun patreon and instagram links will
also be in the description box that's it
for today thank you for watching and i
hope to see you next time
[Music]